hi my name is lynnea and i'm 10 years
old and today i'm having two chefs
compete to make my dream breakfast in
one hour
[Music]
hello
hi lina nice to see you again nice to
see you oh you guys know each other
i actually know linear from the first
season but i lost i'm so happy to cook
for hugging so i can redeem myself so
linea what is your dream breakfast my
dream breakfast is
a
mystical creature breakfast biscuit
pegasus cheese inside pegasus cheese
dragon sausage and then i would have elf
eggs this is all very specific i've
never had elf eggs or pegasus cheese is
there
more on this plate fairy sauce does
fairies eat it it's tomato fairy so i
don't think fairies would like to eat it
so is the fairy sauce or is there
multiple colors or yeah it's like a
rainbow rainbow it's like honey colors
blue purple
oh no i don't know i'm not adding these
dishes get crazy enough and now i'm the
reason she's adding more colors so this
would be sweet this would be salty and
then it would just go in a pattern sweet
salty oh is that a little horn
yeah unicorn fruit white's different
from regular fruit we
unfortunately have to cut the unicorn's
horns off and put them on the floor
cutting off unicorn's horn it's pretty
intense i assume they're gonna have
another home yeah they grow that this
would look like a kiwi yeah way to pick
up on that really yeah what's your
favorite food um i like pineapple and
strawberry blueberries
um apples oranges and bananas do you
like any vegetables well i like carrots
carrots
and i also like broccoli yeah i like
fruit more though this is your dream
breakfast right so you're gonna eat it
what do you think make you feel like
happy happy yeah okay well we're gonna
take this drawing and we're gonna turn
it into a dish do you think we can do it
all i have to say is good luck
okay
all right well we're gonna go get
started
[Music]
here's my plan i am going to use two
jimmy dean biscuit roll-ups as my
mystical breakfast biscuit it's got
everything linnea wanted eggs cheese
sausage all rolled up into a biscuit i'm
going to make rainbow mac and cheese as
my rainbow sauce toasted rainbow
breadcrumbs as my fairy dust and candy
coated fruit with a taffy horn for the
unicorn fruit so she said she likes
vegetables she likes fruit so she seems
like not that picky eater so i'm going
to go for a healthy loud and make linear
and her mom happy for mystical creature
biscuit i'm going to make biscuit from
scratch and put cheese and sausage and
egg bits in it for the unicorn fruit i'm
going to cube fruits i'm going to top
with ice cream corn dipped chocolate
with sprinkles i've completed a lot of i
draw you cook episodes there is no time
limit but this time we have one hour
time limit and it makes me very nervous
i'm not sure if i can finish freezing
right katie are you ready i am are you
what are you gonna start with so i think
i'm gonna make biscuit from scratch
because she said biscuit raw like cheese
and eggs that's gonna take a long time i
know
is it a mistake
we only have an hour i don't think she's
gonna have enough time to make biscuit
dough from scratch and get everything on
her plate in an hour i well i have
mine's a lot faster what i'm gonna do
what you gonna do um i'm making these
jimmy dean biscuit roll-ups oh
yeah because they basically have
everything they've got the sausage the
egg the cheese and i think they're gonna
be done and ready to serve i think in
under two minutes under two minutes i've
never had them before yeah so i'm gonna
try it and they will we'll see these
jimmy dings biscuit roll ups only takes
two minutes to serve my homemade biscuit
takes more than 20 minutes oh it smells
really good oh my god you want to try
some yeah okay
two minutes yeah i only cut butter
right
you might be in trouble cheers oh it's
sausage
cheesy and buttery the biscuit is super
flaky it's a okay fresh stew yeah i
guess three i was gonna say i don't
think you're gonna have enough time do
you want to use some yes i gotta get
started on my other stuff all right
scrub my ideas i'm gonna do my fruit
okay i'm gonna i have veggies to cut so
i'm gonna start with cara
is this for your rainbow yeah so she
draws some like colorful things so like
orange it's gonna be glades to carrot so
it's a little bit sweet
oh and she did say like sweet salty i
think linea will love this rainbow
vegetable because it seems like linnea
has refined palette i'm just worried i
gotta get this sugar up to speed yeah we
never had a time limit before have you
do you cook under time pressure at home
is anyone screaming are you gonna cook
quickly two minutes left you're like
with the time limit it really makes me
feel like i'm on a reality show and i
get to do the thing where like hands up
get your hands off your plate at the end
that's what i'm hoping i am heating up
some sugar and water and a little corn
syrup and then once that gets to the
like hard crack which is like 300 i am
going to dip my fruit in it and i'll
make this nice pretty shell i'm
basically making bunch of sauteed
vegetables
so i'm gonna just cut all my veggie
first and then saute
separately she said salt stone that's my
concern i say sauce do they really want
a sauce yeah true like a saucy sauce
maybe they do yeah i don't know yeah
really is not taking this time limit
very seriously i think she's she's like
smooth sailing i'm like trying to
multitask and do a lot at once i'm
taking little taffy kind of candy i'm
gonna like twirl them around each other
as a unicorn horn would be and now i'm
just going to brush mine with some
edible gold like dust slash glitter so
now i'm just sauteing red onion so it
kind of looks like a popple we got green
red and yellow yellow with the corn i'm
going to do just really quick dips
now
oh i dropped my strawberry it's cool
it's cool
nobody look over here
oh i'm thinking i'm not going to use any
spice because sometimes kids doesn't
like spice
katie is making rainbow mac and cheese i
got a little bit nervous because i've
never met kids doesn't like mac and
cheese i'm going to be making a very
quick mac and cheese with some cream
cheese heavy cream and some white
cheddar and a little salt and then i'm
gonna divide it the sauce into these
five bowls color them and then
mix in fold in my
cooked pasta kids loves food of color
i'm gonna go toast these at 350 for
about like five to seven minutes i'm
making grates to carrot so i put water
and a carrot and bring it to a boil once
carrot is tender i'm going to add brown
sugar and butter while it's cooking i'm
going to cut my fruit into cube shape
like there's a bunch of food scrub
making cube but you can save those for
smoothie later pro tip tasty no wasting
tasty there's no wasted what are you
gonna do for the food
i have ice cream corn oh
that's nice with the fruit like the
texture how much time do we have left 15
minutes
okay okay do you feel yeah i feel great
i'm getting more nervous now i'm going
to
melt chocolate with coconut oil and now
i am folding in my white cheddar and i
really wanted to make a thick sauce so
that would really coat
the pasta
with actual colors
did you just throw shade huh no i'm just
saying thick with t-h-i-c-c-cc
oh yeah
thinking instead of this grain i should
have just done yellow because this green
is
gross
i'm a little worried but my mac and
cheese looks radioactive the green of my
mac and cheese is looking pretty gross
it looks like slime or snot top this
with some of these
my crumblies do you think she's gonna
know that this is mac and cheese before
she comes to bite it like it doesn't
look like mac and cheese i don't know
oh it's so cute thank you
how are you doing rick i just have to um
put some fruits together i was going to
make two tubes but it takes a lot of
time than i thought so i just make one
final step that i need to do is heat up
my jimmy dean biscuit roll-ups and then
i'm all done okay so i'm still a little
behind do you mind heating mine up not
at all i can definitely for you anything
i will literally do anything this dish
seems a little bit too healthy so i
decided to dip banana into a chocolate
did you miss me
i did
that one i have here two biscuits
rolls thank you so much oh cute they're
so cute oh my god they're adorable
well i know she's going to love those
yes
you know everything else a little like
okay cool i'm
done you done i feel good i finished
before riya
let me help you read this this play is
like a coop
this last piece is very difficult
i'm not sure if i can finish on time 30
seconds
oh my god
who's counting down
you got it you got it you got it
we're gonna put your roll-ups on it oh
yeah oh thank god you used those we
would have never made this
[Music]
should we go see what she thinks yeah
all right let's do it
i think lynnae is gonna like the mac and
cheese i think she's gonna be maybe
weirded out by the colors but then i
think she's gonna taste it and love it
the biscuit roll up sit perfectly on the
little rainbow it's like the cloud that
sets the rainbow off i think those
biscuits look perfect i'm very proud of
my dish i think renee will be
impressed with my route i think she will
like that most
bring on my mystical creature breakfast
whoa
this is cool i like how they did all the
different colors i think this is mac and
cheese it's really good i really like
the crunchy bits and i really like the
horns too
the orange looks really similar to how
it does on the drawing it looks nice
i don't like the outside is too sweet
she hates the candy coating i should
just stop using sugar stop using sugar
katie i like these biscuit roll ups
they're really cute i like how it has
the
pegasus cheese and the dragon sausage
she likes the biscuit roll up yes
it was easy and she loved it so
bring on the second dish
this looks really good
i like how everything else looks like my
drawing but
i didn't put any vegetables in there she
said i didn't drop any vegetables and my
palms are getting sweaty i think it's
reya's dish cause she likes to give kids
healthy stuff for some reason i thought
she likes healthy dish but i guess not
it has a kiwi
banana and a strawberry i like the
strawberry hmm
it's chocolate covered banana
i like it it's really good
that's good i like the horn
the biscuit makes me feel really happy
it's really good i'm so glad that katie
gave me jimmy dean biscuit roll ups
because she loved it maybe that's her
favorite thing on my dish
did you have fun yeah did you have fun
eating
eating is always fun yeah um but now
it's time to choose yeah so out of the
two dishes did you like the mac and
cheese dish or did you like the veggie
dish
i liked the macaroni and cheese fish
oh my gosh
do you know this is my first time ever
winning
ever since you won you get to keep my
drawing this is going to go like up on
my mantel hard dish is everything kids
want like colorful and mac and cheese
why did i think i should put vegetable
on kid's plate i won finally i i am so
excited well she hated my unicorn fruit
but i really think it was my mac n
cheese and i think that biscuit roll-up
put me over the edge
[Music]
so
[Music]
you